je suis né à kaboul capitale de
l'afghanistan et à l'époque kaboul
c'était ça aujourd'hui je vous invite à
voyager avec moi juste quelques instants
le temps de traverser les siècles mais
je ne suis pas venu seul
parce que je vous invite aussi à voyager
avec qatar en poète mystique de langue
personnes ma langue maternelle
il ya longtemps disons vers le xiiie
siècle ce poète a écrit un texte très
puissant le cantique des oiseaux dans ce
recueil de poèmes
les oiseaux sont symbole de l'âme
humaine et il vole trouver leur reine
l'asim orgue un oiseau de la mythologie
perse qui vit sur la montagne de cov
évidemment trouver là simorgh était un
prétexte pour comprendre le sens de la
vie le sens de leur existence
et c'est comme ça qu'il commence leur
voyage initiatique en voyage initiatique
est en voyage comme tous les voyages
c'est un passage que vous voyagez à
l'intérieur de vous même ou que vous
changer de continent
vous n'en reviendrez jamais en deuil
passé les frontières
céline arbitraire qui change à travers
le temps et qui nous change et qui
change le dessin de tant de personnes à
travers le monde
eh oui de nos jours naître à kaboul ce
n'est pas la même chose que naître à
paris où comme le dit amin maalouf
l'écrivain franco libanais être femme à
kaboul ce n'est pas exactement la même
chose qu'être femme à oslo
le voyage des oiseaux dans le point de
hathor commence au xiiie siècle
le mien a commencé en octobre 1994
j'avais à peine 13 ans à peine mais il
ya une différence fondamentale entre
août et de voyage parce que les oiseaux
de à tin oo ils font le choix de partir
de chercher de trouver leur haine et de
revenir sur leur terre natale pour moi
partir n'était pas un choix
c'était la dernière
la seule solution ma mère mon père ma
soeur et mon frère nous devions partir
et nous font partie ailleurs laissant
derrière nous beaucoup de choses
peut-être même l'espoir de pouvoir y
revenir un jour parce que l'exil l'exil
ce n'est pas seulement laisser son corps
derrière soi comme le prétendait ovide
l'exil c'est aussi laisser ses mots ses
gestes son regard et sa joie derrière
soi comme le dit atiq rahimi
l'écrivain franco afghan mais revenons
aux oiseaux d'eau at war
les oiseaux de hathor se font tous les
oiseaux du monde qui s'étaient réunis
pour traverser les 7 vallées de l'amour
et rencontrer la divinité simorgh seuls
30 d'entre eux y parviennent parce que
ceux qui n'avaient pas le courage de
continuer avaient abandonné leur quête
au fait savez vous ce que signifie
simorgh en persan simorgh signifie 30
oiseaux c'est 30 oiseaux qui parviennent
accomplir leur voyage initiatique
découvrons que la divinité simorgh était
le reflet de leur propre image
c'est à dire que le sujet de leurs
recherches là simorgh était déjà en eux
et il leur fallait un cheminement pour
la voir enfin quant à moi j'ai traversé
les frontières une première fois à
l'intérieur de ma ville natale kaboul
puis une deuxième fois en 1994 vers
l'iran et enfin une troisième fois en
2003 vers la france treize ans après mon
arrivée en france c'est à dire
aujourd'hui les images des migrants nous
font revenir en arrière et me rappelle
les épreuves de ce long voyage vers
l'exil par seul existe n'est qu'une
conséquence mais la conséquence de quoi
on pense bien la guerre à la famine à la
dictature mais je me demande pourquoi
ces guerres pourquoi ces familles
pourquoi ces dictatures en fait je me
demande si la vie était en voyage un
envol vers ailleurs et nous tous des
oiseaux vers quelle destination
nous aimerions partir quel monde nous
aimerions construire pour nous et pour
les générations futures
et si vous aviez le choix vous choisirez
la guerre la famine la dictature je
pense que nous rêvons tous d'un monde
meilleur et certain laurent meyer au
quotidien laissez moi vous raconter une
anecdote personnelle
deux ans après mon arrivée en france
j'ai dû m'inscrire dans un lycée pour
passer le bac à lorient j'ai rencontré
la proviseur michel une dame que
j'apprécie beaucoup
je lui dis que je voulais avoir le bac
puis faire des études universitaires
pour devenir prof ce que je suis
aujourd'hui
ce jour-là elle m'avait écouté m'avait
du tout simplement oui tout peut le
faire ces cinq mots oui tu peux le faire
ont changé ma vie d'une certaine façon
parce que ce jour là j'ai eu le
sentiment d'être enfin chez moi
quelque part onze ans plus tard c'est à
dire aujourd'hui je me demande ce que je
peux faire un bon tour ce que nous
pouvons faire pour que l'exil ne soit
plus une fatalité pour que l'espoir ne
meurt pas dans cette salle on m'a dit
que vous êtes plus de 800
c'est beaucoup c'est un peu plus que le
nombre d'exilés qui en ont péri dans un
naufrage
seulement le 20 avril dernier
en fait les 30 d'oiseaux qui réussissent
leur voyage initiatique découvre que la
divinité était le reflet de leur propre
image et nous et nous le monde dans
lequel nous vivons reflètent ils
vraiment ce que nous ferons